today I'm gonna talk about the small RNA
revolution that occurred between 1990
and today and how that emerged my name
is Gary Rothman I'm a professor of
genetics at Harvard Medical School
one learns is an undergraduate the
central dogma of molecular biology where
DNA makes RNA that makes proteins and
small RNAs have modified that over the
last 20 years the first example of the
modification was the micro RNAs that
I'll go into a great detail today and
they are thought to be made from very
small transcripts 22 nucleotides long
that then regulate the translation of
target mRNAs to then cause less protein
products so it's another layer of
regulation but in addition to micro
rna's there is also many other tiny RNAs
that are made inside of cells that
probably regulate the production of RNA
from genes and and also add a regulatory
locus and those were discovered at about
the same time and I'll talk about that
too so the star of the show is C elegans
the nematode and this is the animal that
is not as big as my arm it's a
millimetre long and it has been a
subject of thousands of researchers
worldwide who work on it it started as a
field by sydney brenner in the early 60s
as the most simple complicated animal to
work on the worm is an animal and it's
phylogenetically related to us up here
but pretty distant and much simplified
as an animal and so simple that instead
of having billions of cells it has 959
cells as a full-grown adult this is the
lineage of the animal that was worked
out by john sulston in the early 70s
this is showing the pattern of divisions
that take place in the embryo these are
the divisions that take place during
larval stage one you can see here larval
stage two larval stage 3 larval stage
four and out pops an adult
and it produces progeny every three days
so it's a very fast genetic system that
attracted a lot of talent and the field
of C elegans has always been very
influential to me in particular
it's just populated with really
wonderful people who work on many
different biological problems and I've
always felt blessed to have been
surrounded by people who work on so many
different aspects of the biology of this
animal it's a way to learn everything
about biology and a microcosm on one
organism the particular project that
I'll be describing in detail was started
in at the MRC which was the center the
Medical Research Council the center of
where worms started at Sydney Brenner's
lab actually Marty Chaffee started this
project
discovering the limb for mutation back
in the mid 70s and this is a mutation
that causes lineage changes and those
lineage changes look like changes in
time so if you look at the wild-type
lineage over here this complicated
pattern of divisions that takes place in
the larval stage one is only takes place
in larval stage one in wild-type but yet
in a limb for it goes at the l1 l2 l3
and l4 stage keeps reiterating so this
animal is [ __ ] it never really gets
to the adult stage it always has
patterns of division as if it's a larval
arveleï animal and what really sort of
launched this project to be really
important to do was when Victor Ambrose
began to work on it when he was a
postdoc in bob horvitz his lab in the
early 80s and discovered the gene lin-14
could suppress mutations in lynn for so
it could take this complicated set of
divisions that are temporally aberrant
and instead of doing l1 l1 l1 it would
go straight to l2 and therefore have a
pattern of divisions that's distinct in
time and this allowed him to infer that
Lyne for was a negative regulator of the
gene lin-14 to set up this how
developmental timing works and so Victor
and I worked together as postdocs on
this project to try and figure out how
Lin four and Lin 14 regulate from a
regulatory access to set set up the
timing of the animal so we together
identified the genetic locus the the the
the actual molecular basis of Lin 14 and
what we've the first thing we figured
out was that mutations that activate the
Lin 14 gene are deletions not of the
open reading frame of the gene here it's
downstream of the open reading frame but
actually mutations in the three prime
untranslated region or a translocation
of the three prime untranslated region
that takes these conserved regions shown
in gray and either deletes them or or
translocates them away so that said that
there's like off switch on the link 14
gene and this is part of the off switch
and the way it gets turned off is by
this negative regulator linen for shown
here and so what was Lin for and the key
breakthrough here came out of Victor's
lab when he was a an assistant professor
at Harvard and what his lab figured out
Roslyn Lee and Rhonda Finebaum and
Victor was that Lin for didn't code for
a protein at all it codes for a very
small RNA that's 22 nucleotides long
that's shown in the gray box here and
the precursor of Lin for it's shown as
this double-stranded RNA and this RNA is
up regulated right at the time of l1
which fits with the phenotype that what
we were studying so after the Ambrose
lab figured out that Lin for codes a
tiny RNA we Victor and I compared the
sequence of his Lin 4 shown on the
bottom strand here to the sequence of
Lin 14 assuming that it might be a
direct interaction which you never know
if it's direct or indirect in biology
but let's assume simplicity and so we
could immediately see that there were
seven different sites
the lin-14 utr and so they're numbered
one through seven here and for example
here's number one and that's shown over
here there's a top strand is lin-14 the
bottom strand is lin four and in every
case there was duplex but you can notice
that it's not a perfect duplex so the
lin 4 will bulge us see here it will
bulge an AC see you see a over here and
each one had a sort of a non perfect
duplex on the other hand we could see by
evolutionary comparisons comparing the
sequence of lin 14 on the top strand to
between sin arab Dittus elegans and
briggsie that all the bolded letters are
conserved between c elegans and super
eggsy so that said that the sequence of
this is is important enough for the
animal to have conserved it over many
millions of years and so we proved that
this these elements were important by
moving this three prime UTR and the
reporter genes and knocking out these
sites to prove it was important and this
was the first example of a regulatory
RNA that was that small in the case of
Lin form and it was much smaller than
any other regulatory RNA for example the
u RNAs or more like a hundred
nucleotides than 20 nucleotides in this
if the developmental biology community
it was the community we were a part of
that he included for example many c
elegans geneticists manager softly
geneticists they paid attention to this
we definitely talked about this at
Gordon conferences and things like that
but there was always a view that this is
a kind of our quirky thing that maybe a
quirk of the lineage of C elegans
because remember we're dealing with with
a lineage here which was a distinct way
to think about developmental biology and
really a sort of marginal in comparison
to how the wider developmental biology
community thought more about tissue
interactions and cell interactions and
so yes we presented it at meetings and
things like
but it wasn't really there wasn't a
stampede for people to start to work on
that that's for sure on the other hand
the regulatory RNA community the people
who work on the ribosome and how tRNA is
bind to the acceptor sites that sort of
thing
splicing they were totally enthralled
with this and so it it was exciting to
us to sort of be thrust into the
regulatory RNA community remember we're
coming as developmental biologists what
what we happen to find a regulatory RNA
and its target thrusts us into a new
ecosystem and that ecosystem informed us
in many ways
it's very sophisticated that how the
ribosomal RNA folds how the ribosome
works these are these are inspirational
fields and it's one of the great things
about biology is that these disease
islands of specialization and you can
learn a lot from each Island and biology
teaches us that that that islands are
where the the most extreme variation
occurs so how does the Lin for micro RNA
work well it Lin for gets up regulated
at the l1 stage and that causes less
production of the lin-14 protein that's
its target but it doesn't really affect
the mRNA levels nearly as much as it
affects the protein levels so that said
that the way micro rna's work this one
micro RNA is by regulating the
translation of target proteins we still
don't know even 20 years later exactly
how that's working it's still an object
of much research in in micro rna's the
next stage right now we're at 1993
approximately the next stage is seven
years later when we start doing genetics
to try and fill out the rest of the
pathway to figure out who else is being
regulated to specify these lineages and
we get let's Evan as a suppressor of a
Weakland 14 mutation and when we figure
out what let-7 is we figure out that
it's another micro in a in this case
looks a lot like the first one is
homologous at all but it's analogous it
has the same stem-loop structure the
gray box as the 22 nucleotide product of
that and in this case the the let-7
micro RNA when we compared its sequence
across emerging databases now remember
this is the year 2000 as opposed to 1992
so genome databases are much more
sophisticated the human genome in the
year 2000 is about 30% done so we could
compare it to the 30% done genome
sequence not by doing northern blots or
anything like that but by just doing a
blast and analysis just asking is the
nucleotides conserved and boom we could
see it 20 seconds later and that was an
amazing moment because the activation
energy to actually do a northern blot or
some kind of experiment to look for
conservation there's takes some oomph to
do that but looking in a genome you
could do it in 20 seconds to know the
answer and so we sort of instantly knew
that let-7 was conserved in flies and
more in humans in genome sequences but
we also had to of course prove that it
was a small RNA so we did do a lot of
northern blots to a whole zoo of
creatures and that was very influenced
by a comparative developmental biology
conferences that Eric Davidson had run
it at marine biological labs where I'm
actually giving this speaking to this
camera right now now at about the same
time that we were finding this second
mic Rene in the year 2000 fire and
mellow and baulkham and Hamilton had
found that tiny RNAs are produced by in
RNA interference which was a very hot
topic at that point it was very
mysterious how injecting double-stranded
RNAs and de organisms would inactivate
genes and Hamilton and Baulkham found 22
nucleotide RNAs
I was enthralled by the fact that the
micro rna's and the the srna's are the
same size and I remembered the number 22
was an important number in the
Kabbalistic numerology
and sort of as a yuk I found websites to
show my lab and they they worried about
me doing this much more productive was
to say okay if if they produce it the
same size RNAs maybe they use some of
the same enzymology and the enzymes that
take double-stranded RNAs and chop them
into srna's were being discovered for
example by greg Hannan's lab at Cold
Spring Harbor and so we could do the
experiment of in activating the gene for
that double stranded RNA Dicer are an
ace Dicer and show that that was
actually important in how microRNAs get
processed as well the other importance
of the of the synchrony of the
discoveries of the RNA AI pathway and
the micro pathway is that there was a
huge interest in RNA I as a tool the C
elegans community was probably the one
of the very first genetic communities to
start using RNA I in a big way but it
also started to having a lot plants and
once si RNAs were discovered in animals
they started to be used all over animal
labs so the the interest in it is a tool
was was immense and it made the interest
in micro rna's and small arrays in
general much larger than it would have
been if it was just my current ease
so after let-7 was discovered as a as a
conserved micro neighs there was a
concerted effort to purify by cloning
many different micro rna's and actually
victor Ambrose's lab was one of the
first to do that along with the Bartel
lab and the touch' lab and many
microRNAs were discovered and within a
year or two there were thousands of
known my current a's and the current
census must be tens of thousands of
micro rna's and it is known now that
micro rna's regulate many many different
targets and are regulating those targets
to regulate all kinds of processes they
work everywhere from floral development
in plants to perhaps how memories are
formed there's thousands and thousands
of papers on micro rna's in all
different fields from plants and animal
more generally the small RNA field it's
thought that there's many sources of
double-stranded RNAs one of those
sources is micro RNAs as I started with
but there's also viral double-stranded
RNAs repeats in the genome they go
through this process of making tiny RNAs
using Dicer and various other components
and they then regulate gene expression
they regulate gene expression but by a
variety of mechanisms the ones I've told
you about so far are translational
repression and RNA degradation which si
RNAs mediate by simply causing cleavage
more mysterious is the regulation of
heterochromatin that also involves small
RNAs and how that histone modification
responds to small RNAs is a big mystery
today thank you very much
you